Mimi is with us in New York hi Mimi how
are you
good afternoon mr. Ramsey thank you for
letting me speak sure
so mr. Ramsey I had a property in New
York and if I sell this property I am
going to net between 200 and 250
thousand dollars from the sale and I am
wondering if I and I have a student loan
debt of one hundred and eighty five
thousand dollars good lord
oh I'm longer no no school in New York
is very expensive not that expensive
what did your degree in I mastered and I
have a double degree in organizational
management and entrepreneurship from the
top School in New York yeah great great
so what's your household income well
this year it's been a rough year so I
will clear 150,000 okay
well that's good news okay would I sell
a piece of property to pay off one
hundred eighty five thousand dollars in
student loan debt yes I would Mike what
like I knew you would say that because
what my question was but could be
alternative to that be putting the money
and an index fund and using the interest
to pay it all off over you know say like
10 years let's pretend you could borrow
a million dollars in student loans and
you would invest them in an index fund
and use that money to pay it off in over
10 years would you do that and that's it
I know I okay no no you would not do
that and the reason is the reason I
bring the example then I make it large
is it makes you feel the risk that you
apparently didn't feel when you were
borrowing on your student loan debt in
order to invest in mutual funds
our index funds I like index funds I
like mutual funds but there's risk
inherent and those and then I when we
studied ten thousand millionaires we
talked to zero of the ten thousand that
said you know I refuse to pay off my
debt instead I used all the money while
I stayed deeply in debt to invest and
that's what made me wealthy none of them
said that zero out of ten thousand all
of them had a very similar story to I
became wealthy because I got out of debt
and I steadily invested not because I
borrowed money to invest it just wasn't
there we didn't find anybody that did
this and so it's it's a set of math that
assumes no risk is why you don't think
that you're not perceiving that there's
actual risk between a student loan debt
being there which adds a risk to your
portfolio and then you've got your money
invested in the stock market which is
volatile and you know and you're gonna
ride that way if there's risk there it's
not usually back-breaking risk but it
doesn't lead you to wealth we have no
data points of people doing that on a
large scale that causes it and so we're
always going to lead you your shortest
path to wealth and is because the
debt-free place gives you not only a
place of high cash flow so you can
invest but it also gives you a place
that is solid you're on solid ground
that doesn't move and when things go up
and down and sideways and up and down in
sideways everybody takes one step
forward three steps back four steps
forward and seven steps back and then
all this gyration and rhythm in these
people's lives that take risk all the
time and so now I'm gonna tell you to
pay off the student loan debt and I'm
really sorry that you went that far in
debt for that degree